Redwoods live for millennia.
The record is like 2,200 years.
But it's not uncommon for
trees like that one.
Or this one that I'm sitting on, to
live for upwards of hundreds of years.
So enjoy a brief introduction to trees.
In the next part of the lesson, you'll
be doing a problem set where you'll be
applying everything that you've learned
about building websites so far.
If you run into any problems,
just think back to your plan
from the first project.
You have all the tools, techniques and
support that you need to
push through anything.
In the meantime, congratulations.
You've taken a huge first step in
your career as a web developer.
Okay, well maybe it's not
as big as these giants.
But still, you should be proud.
After you finish up the problem
set in the project after that,
you'll be learning about style and
how to add it to your website.
Good luck.